Xiaomi est en train de réinventer
l'interface homme machine alors je vous
explique pourquoi en fait Xiaomi vient
de lancer des lunettes à réalité
augmentée et en quoi c'est extrêmement
intéressant et bien parce que ça fait
partie de l'évolution je dirais naturel
d'où vont aller tous les fabricants de
ce smartphone pourquoi regardez c'est
très simple vous avez tout comprendre
aujourd'hui l'interface de machine c'est
ce truc là de marque différente c'est un
smartphone et un smartphone ça fait quoi
va faire tout ce que vous faites et
peut-être regarder cette vidéo tout de
suite sauf que vous devez l'avoir à la
main c'est bien des fois on peut venir
étendre l'expérience avec une montre
connectée c'est pratique mais on est
rapidement limité et donc tous les
fabricants de smartphones réfléchissent
à se dire où est-ce qu'on va aller
demain comment ça va se passer et il est
évident qu'on doit réinventer une
interface beaucoup plus simple en ayant
les mains libres et en ayant moins de
contraintes parce qu'un smartphone même
si c'est pratique même si des fois il y
a un côté un peu libérateur ça reste une
contrainte dans le creux de la main donc
Xiaomi se dit comme beaucoup d'acteurs
on va venir changer l'histoire avec des
lunettes à réalité augmentée comme ça
vous allez avoir votre contenu
directement sur votre tronche et pouvoir
venir interagir avec je vous expliquerai
en fait plein de choses avec donc Xiaomi
présente ses nouvelles lunettes
connectées ça se passe ici au MWC 2023
c'est passionnant vous allez voir vous
êtes prêt allez on y va
[Applaudissements]
comme ils aiment bien se marrer un peu
chez Xiaomi ils nous ont mis un nom un
peu à coucher dehors accrochez-vous
l'air on se parle ici des Xiaomi ou
wireless AR Smart glace Discovery
edition oui s'il vous plaît il y a
beaucoup de mots pour parler de lunettes
connectées en réalité augmentée alors
qu'est-ce qu'elles vont faire c'est
lunettes en réalité augmentée et bien
vous venez les poser sur votre thème
jusqu'à là tout va bien on peut pas le
faire tout de suite j'ai pas pu les
essayer je les ai vu ils nous ont fait
une démonstration au petit comité dans
une petite pièce est et on le voit
vraiment en avant-première donc c'est
une chance et c'est super cool de voir
la vision de Xiaomi là-dessus donc la
démo c'est vous posez vos lunettes il y
a deux types de verre des verres un peu
plus clair et des verres un peu plus
fumé alors on peut imaginer que
peut-être ces vers clairs vont devenir
des Verts fumées en fonction du besoin
grâce à côté électronique à voir je sais
pas si ça va être comme ça ça va se
passer ça peut potentiellement être ça
et l'idée c'est que lorsque vous avez
besoin que vous baladez dans la rue vous
voulez avoir par exemple du guidage avec
un Google Maps ou je que sais-je qu'on
sort et compagnie et bien vous allez
voir qu'il va s'afficher de la réalité
augmentée on connaît tous les radios
augmenter c'est pratique et ça ça va
bien et lorsque vous voulez un peu plus
d'inversion vous voulez par exemple
regarder un film on peut venir regarder
un film avec des détails augmenter on
s'approche davantage de la réalité mixte
et bien on va venir fumer un petit peu
ses lunettes pour se couper du monde qui
nous entoure et pouvoir voir grâce à ses
écrans vous avez deux petits écrans avec
des écrans micro OLED vous allez pouvoir
voir un film regardez prendre des choses
ça peut aussi être relativement
intéressant alors une fois de plus c'est
pas essayé c'est vraiment un conseil
pour l'instant c'est une première
version une première itération donc on
verra plus tard ce qui arrivera ils nous
ont fait une démo qui de gaming parce
qu'il faut qu'on regarde un peu les
usages alors il y a un côté un peu
ludique pour le gaming ils avaient leur
smartphone j'imagine un Xiaomi 13 13 pro
peut-être aller savoir et bien il voyait
lui sur la table en face des petits
monstres qui venaient qu'attaquer et lui
il venait les shooter directement avec
son smartphone on voyait que ça
projetait directement des lasers donc il
y a un côté un peu ludique sur de la
réalité augmentée ça c'est assez marrant
on peut venir également imaginer parce
que ça vient reconnaître les mains ça
vient reconnaître les articulations de
vos doigts grâce à des caméras qui sont
à l'extérieur de vos lunettes sur vos
lunettes mais qui viennent filmer à
l'extérieur ça me paraît logique parce
que si ça me fait filmer votre front ça
nous reste strictement aucun intérêt
donc on peut très bien imaginer j'en
sais rien moi de la modélisation aux
trois dimensions on peut venir déplacer
des choses donc il y a un usage aussi
très professionnel et puis fatalement un
usage pour la maison la démo qui nous
ont fait c'est de se dire ok vous voyez
votre lampe qui est chez vous et bien
avec vos lunettes grâce à un geste vous
venez vous appuyer ça éteint
l'interrupteur donc il y a aussi un côté
qui est très immersif très intéressant
dans votre intérieur on allume la télé
on baisse la lampe on peut imaginer
beaucoup d'usage dans votre maison
connectée donc vous voyez c'est un
élément central on vient se trancher
dans le futur hein tout de suite mais ça
pourrait vraiment devenir un élément
central la maison connectée et par
extension bien évidemment votre voiture
connectée Xiaomi peut-être parce qu'ils
sont en train de travailler sur la
voiture connectée et par extension bien
évidemment dans votre usage
professionnel et puis par extension le
soir vous les gardez et vous regardez un
petit film donc il y a plein d'usages
possibles intéressants une fois de plus
l'idée c'est de réinventer l'interface
homme machine c'est tout ce que vous
faites avec votre smartphone et bien
vous pourriez le faire avec vos lunettes
de réalité augmentée réalité mixte j'ai
plus envie de dire aujourd'hui je suis
au milieu de sa première version on voit
qu'il y a déjà d'autres marques qui
travaillent dessus depuis un petit
moment oppo MWC nous montre une deuxième
version de leurs lunettes connectées
alors j'ai plus d'essayer l'année
dernière on peut également les essayer
ici c'est évolué c'est intéressant mais
on n'y est pas complètement ça finit de
prendre son envol et se démocratiser il
y a également TCL qui travaille dessus
avec des lunettes à réalité augmentée et
de la réalité mixte donc voyez ça va
arriver on y est pas pour tout de suite
mais ça va arriver alors on se parle
bien évidemment de lunettes sans fil
sans quoi ça serait pas rigolo on va
parler un peu tac à essayer de
comprendre comment ça fonctionne à
l'intérieur après vous avez un affichage
l'écran vient vraiment se positionner en
face de votre éthique en tout cas ce
qu'on nous annonce ici qui va venir
s'adapter en plus à l'environnement
lumineux parce que vous avez deux écrans
ma parole on s'en doutera c'est du micro
OLED je vous l'ai dit vous avez un
capteur de luminosité qui fait que
lorsque vous êtes dans un endroit très
lumineux on peut imaginer en plein
soleil à l'extérieur et bien ça va
envoyer un peu plus de pêche et lorsque
vous êtes le soir dans votre lit vous
avez besoin d'un petit peu moins de
lumière vous voulez pas envoyer beaucoup
de lumière au niveau de votre œil et
bien c'est l'avenir baisser ça donc
venir moduler l'intensité lumineuse et
lorsque vous êtes en extérieur vous
pouvez monter jusqu'à 1200000 de
luminosité au niveau des écrans on se
parle ici d'une très faible latence
Hotmail vos lunettes une intense de 3
millisecondes et ça tourne sur une
plateforme de qualcoon c'est la star
dragon
xa2n1 alors si vous avez suivi quand je
vous parle de quoi alcool mais lorsque
je viens montrer les nouvelles puces qui
nous emmène à l'autre bout du monde à
Hawa et bien il parle effectivement
beaucoup de réalité augmentée de réalité
mixte c'est un sujet qui est très
important sur lequel comme se positionne
depuis des années et ce qui permet
effectivement à des constructeurs comme
Xiaomi bien d'avoir les outils pour
venir développer du matériel et toute la
partie logiciel avec ses plateformes de
Qualcomm alors il va falloir le coupler
avec un smartphone qui va être
compatible forcément et si c'est du coup
alcool avec notamment le stade dragon
space le Xiaomi trace face allemand
fonctionnera et vous le fera là-dessus
alors pour autant c'est une aide sont
pas encore à acheter donc bon oui on
reste encore un peu tranquille des
lunettes qui sont annoncées comme étant
légères qu'on ne se rend pas en tout cas
la sensation sur votre tête elles font
126 g elles sont en alliage de magnésium
et lithium pour apporter de la légèreté
et de la robustesse malgré tout avec
notamment des pièces également en fibre
de carbone et on va retrouver trois
tailles tourner parce que forcément
c'est des lunettes on va pas tout savoir
le même pif on a donc trois tailles
d'embouts différents pour que ça va
s'adapter au nez de tout le monde et
même les grands et les petits nez vous
voyez il y en a pour tout le monde et
alors je vous vois arriver vous ok ça
c'est bien mignon mais moi je suis myope
par exemple il me faut des lunettes je
peux pas mettre mes lunettes de lunettes
de réalité augmentée par-dessus non
soyons clairs mais par contre Xiaomi a
pensé à tout et je vous propose des
clips à venir positionner pour des
personnes mieux alors je sais pas
réellement à quoi elles vont ressembler
comment elles vont être faites néanmoins
c'est plus clips sont là pour être là en
tout cas avoir bien évidemment lorsque
le produit sera lancé et lorsque cette
gamme de produits sera lancée chez
Xiaomi également ailleurs de toute façon
forcément ils vont venir y penser donc
vous voyez que c'est intéressant de voir
comment un constructeur majeur comme
Xiaomi qui fait ici du 360 degrés on le
voit ici au MWC vous présente bien
évidemment leur
nouveau son mari avec Leica notamment le
Xiaomi 13 pro que je vous ai déjà
présenté sur ma chaîne youtube ça c'est
cool il y a également de la robotique
avec le cyber one avec le Cyberdog il y
a toute la maison connectée dans la
cuisine dans le salon bref partout
Xiaomi est là 360 degrés et commence
voyez à préparer le terrain pour
l'avenir en se disant on va réinventer
l'interface homme machine comment est-ce
qu'on peut se transformer l'avenir donc
je trouve que c'est vraiment de la
prospection va vraiment regarder
beaucoup plus loin on y est pas tout de
suite clairement mais on essaye de
regarder ce qui peut se passer à 5 10
ans peut-être même avant allez savoir
d'ailleurs vous qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez quel sera la prochaine étape
après le smartphone il est évident qu'il
y aura une étape après le smartphone
est-ce que vous croyez effectivement au
fait d'avoir des lunettes à réalité
augmentée est-ce que vous croyez plutôt
à des lentilles est-ce que ça vous
plairez quel est le format qui vous
plairait davantage alors bien évidemment
on peut plus facilement mettre une
batterie dans des lunettes que dans des
lentilles c'est quand même relativement
plus compliqué vu les technologies
actuelles et puis en plus de ça dans
cette question de l'interface on imagine
et je l'ai déjà d'ailleurs parlé en
format court sur Youtube Instagram un
peu partout et bien il y a des boîtes
qui travaillent justement cette
interface homme machine pour pouvoir
piloter les choses par la pensée on peut
le faire aujourd'hui avec des mouvements
fin au niveau de la mâchoire c'est la
voiture française qui fait ça mais plus
tard on pourra le faire grâce aux ondes
cérébrales donc c'est intéressant vous
voyez ça évolue donc dites-moi vous ce
que vous en pensez comment est-ce que
vous entrapercevez le futur et puis
est-ce que ça peut vous intéresser de
venir piloter les choses par la pensée
ça s'affiche directement sur vos yeux on
en reparlera pas tout de suite parce que
parce que quand même de choses un peu au
long cours mais je trouve ça extrêmement
passionnant voilà parce que vous en
pensez en commentaire et nous on se
retrouve très bientôt bien évidemment
pour continuer à parler avec je vous
embrasse prenez soin de vous et à très
bientôt Ciao
[Musique]